lo que yo quiero hacer en este vídeo es
algo parecido a lo que viene el vídeo
pasado pero ahora am algo más concreto
digamos que el año es tomemos por
simplicidad al año 1996 1996 las tasas
de interés actuales en este año en las
que yo usaré números enteros no deben
ser exactos pero bueno siempre y cuando
pues entendamos la idea general digamos
que las tasas de interés actuales en
1996 para eeuu son del 8% y digamos que
en tailandia en tailandia las tasas de
interés son de changos los puse mal
dejarlo ok así está mejor tailandia son
del 12% las tasas de interés en
tailandia y bueno en el vídeo pasado
recordemos que estábamos hablando de
tener una discrepancia en la tasa de
interés su tasa de cambio está vinculada
por el banco central de tailandia está
siendo manejada manipulada y bueno esto
puede ser una tentadora forma para que
alguna institución financiera bueno pues
haga su buen dinero
vamos a suponer lo siguiente que tú eres
una am tú vas a ser una institución
tailandesa y pides un préstamo de un
millón de dólares aquí es donde todo se
todo se hace más concreto es el año de
1996 la tasa de cambio está en 25 en
moneda tailandesa por cada dólar así que
tú conviertes tu pediste prestado un
millón en 8% y lo conviertes a 25
millones en moneda de tailandia así que
bueno conviertes en 25 millones inmune
de tailandia que son los bats y luego lo
prestas a 12% lo prestas a 12% ahora
digamos por simplicidad que este es un
préstamo de interés solamente donde el
plazo termina en dos años así que
llamemos esto un préstamo de dos años y
bueno veamos qué sucede cómo puedes
hacer dinero mientras que la moneda se
mantenga estable y como este préstamo
acabará contigo derrotando te si algo
sucede con la moneda especialmente hablo
yo de una devaluación en la moneda
tailandesa relativa al dólar
mientras las dos monedas estén estables
cada año tú lograrás el 25 por ciento de
los 25 millones de moneda de tailandia
que prestaste eso es 12 por ciento de 25
millones es como más o menos 4 millones
bueno mejor lo calculó bien para ti así
que bueno 25 millones por por punto 12
eso guau es 33 millones no 4 jaime me
equivoqué ya no sé hacer cálculos bueno
entonces eso te dará 3 millones por año
en moneda de tailandia y eso eso es un
interés así que bueno tú vas a obtener
tú obtendrás 3 millones moneda de
tailandia que vendrán de quien pidió el
préstamo 3 millones luego para pagar el
interés de ese millón prestado puedes
convertir tendrás 25 moneda de tailandia
por cada dólar hay que convertirlo a
dólares así que 3 millones dividido
entre 25 todo esto está en millones por
lo tanto aquí serán 120 mil dólares 120
mil dólares así que lo conviertes en
esta dirección
irán y lo conviertes a 120 mil dólares y
cuánto interés hay que pagar
bueno pues debes pagar 8% en el millón
lo cual serían 80 mil dólares así que le
restamos 80 mil dólares en interés menos
80 mil dólares
y te quedas con 40 mil dólares por cada
año 40 mil dólares por cada año en
ganancia imagínate estos con un millón
imagínate con un billón de dólares estás
obteniendo esto que parece una ganancia
casi fuera de riesgo y la razón por la
que digo yo
la palabra casi es porque esto es
contingente al hecho de que esta tasa se
mantenga estable entonces veamos cómo
pueden las cosas salir mal cuando ocurre
esta devaluación en la moneda en
tailandia en primer lugar se convertirá
más difícil sacar este interés así que
um de repente la moneda manejada en
tailandia se devalúa y digamos que vas a
bueno voy a elegir aquí un punto elegir
el que sea supongamos que este de aquí y
bueno llegas a una situación en la que
en la que estás a 45 por cada dólar lo
voy a poner aquí hay una devaluación
donde ahora tenemos 45 en moneda
manejada en tailandia por cada dólar acá
teníamos 25 bats por cada dólar es el
nombre de la moneda tailandesa y esto
está ocurriendo en 1997 ahora veamos la
dinámica
3 millones en moneda manejada en
tailandia lo presta este en este tipo de
moneda entonces 3 millones de bahts
serán cuántos dólares la calculadora
aquí están ahora tendrás 3 millones y
tendrás 45 bats por cada dólar eso nos
da aproximadamente 67 mil dólares
entonces esto es equivalente en la nueva
tasa de cambio claro equivalente a 67
mil dólares 67 mil dólares pero el
interés que tú debes en el préstamo del
millón es de 80 mil dólares así que
debemos restar menos 80 mil dólares en
interés por lo tanto tienes menos 13.000
menos 13.000 en déficit
tendrás que pagar lo tus chispas rayos
qué mala onda ahora todo está en contra
tuya porque porque bueno es no no es la
parte fea del asunto no no no todavía
hay más porque quizás tú puedas bueno
decir ok lo pago está bien no hay
problema lo horrible es pagar el
préstamo de dos años porque recuerda que
en 1998 tendrás que pagar el millón que
pediste prestado y bueno si todo hubiera
salido bien si la tasa de
si hubiera quedado estable las personas
a quienes les presta el dinero ese
dinero lo lo conviertes en un millón y
bueno me pagas la deuda no hay problema
pero no pasó eso no se mantuvo estable
porque hubo una devaluación en 1998 así
que ese dinero a quienes les prestas te
y bueno supongamos que lo prestas te
responsablemente por tu préstamo
obtendrás 25 millones en moneda de
tailandia y ya no podrás convertirlos al
millón de dólares ya no no no claro que
no tendremos que dividir este número por
45 25 dividido por 45 se convertirá
aproximadamente en 556 mil dólares así
que 500 quinientos cincuenta y seis mil
dólares lo cual es bastante malo porque
tú debes un millón de dólares entonces
quedarás debiendo todavía 450 mil
dólares es jugártela muy fuerte
solamente por esos 40 mil dólares porque
la moneda tailandia se devalúa y puedes
imaginar las personas vieron esto venir
y por cualquier razón motivo
circunstancia ellos tuvieron miedo
empezaron a convertir
fuera del país dejaron de invertir en
tailandia se dieron cuenta de que bueno
muchas de estas inversiones pudieron ir
a un rumbo por ejemplo a una burbuja
especulativa entonces cuando aparece
aparente que podría haber una crisis
bancaria porque bancos e instituciones
formales estaban haciendo estos
intercambios lo cual podría dar un bajón
a todo el sistema financiero tailandés
entonces bueno todo esto fue una
profecía los inversionistas tendrían
miedo de invertir y bueno mucha más
gente se saldría de hacer tratos y las
reservas del banco de tailandia se
terminarían obviamente aún más aún más
que esto la ciudadanía tendría miedo del
sector bancario y tiene a los bancos y
bueno dirían ok dame de vuelta mis
depósitos entonces los bancos tampoco
tendrán las reservas para pagarlo y
antes de que los bancos den el golpe
justamente aquí las personas lo verán
desde antes venir así que todo el
sistema caerá